la siguiente tabla de contingencia de
frecuencia muestra datos sobre el
ingreso y el grado académico de los
compañeros de trabajo de toma completa
la siguiente tabla de contingencia de
frecuencias relativas por renglón si es
necesario redondear tus respuestas a la
centésima más cercana y aquí tenemos
esta tabla en este lado tenemos a todos
los compañeros de toma que tienen un
título universitario y aquí abajo
tenemos aquellos compañeros que no
tienen título universitario en esta
columna vemos a aquellos que reciben un
ingreso inferior a 30.000 dólares y en
nuestra columna tenemos los que tienen
un ingreso igual o superior a 30 mil
dólares y la tabla que nos piden llenar
la tabla de contingencia de frecuencias
relativas por renglón es esta esta es la
tabla que tenemos que completar vemos
que está este renglón título
universitario aquí va a estar el
porcentaje o la proporción de aquellos
que tienen título universitario del
total de personas que tienen título
universitario que son compañeros de
trabajo de tom
en un ingreso inferior a 30.000 y aquí
van a estar aquellos que tienen un
ingreso igual o superior a 30.000
también que tienen título universitario
la suma de estos dos me tiene que dar
este 1 de aquí lo mismo pasa con este
renglón de aquí abajo
este uno representa mi total de
compañeros de toma que no tienen título
universitario y aquí vamos a poner
aquella proporción del total de estas
personas sin título que tiene un ingreso
inferior a 30.000 y otra a quien
aquellos y el total de compañeros sin
título que tienen un ingreso igual o
superior a 30.000 bueno veamos aquí me
está diciendo a aquellos que tienen
título universitario y que tienen un
ingreso inferior a 30.000 lo que voy a
poner aquí es poner esta cantidad del
número de personas de compañeros de tomb
sin título universitario con ingreso
inferior a 30.000 que son 5 pero lo voy
a comparar voy a ver la proporción de
éstos contra el total de compañeros que
si tienen un título universitario y
vemos el total son esos 5 que tienen el
ingreso inferior a 30.000
estos 14 que tienen el ingreso igual o
superior a 30.000 así que esto va a ser
5 entre 5 más 14 y cuánto es 5 14 pues
va a ser 19 así voy a expresar esos
elementos mientras los voy a dejar así
después en el cálculo que me piden aquí
tengo que poner aquellos compañeros que
tienen título universitario que son 14
que tienen un ingreso igual o superior a
30.000 pero comparado contra el total de
compañeros con título universitario que
ya queremos que es 19 y la misma lógica
sigue aquí abajo solo que ahora tengo
que comparar cada uno de estos elementos
contra el total de compañeros que no
tienen título universitario que en este
caso van a ser estos 16 más estos 7 16
más 7 van a ser 23 así que los que no
tienen título y ganan menos de 30.000
son 16 estos 16 pero no os voy a
comparar contra el total que
son 23 y ahora tengo estos 7 que no
tienen título universitario pero ganan
más o igual que 30.000 son 7 entre el
total de compañeros sin título que son
23 bueno lo tenemos así pero ahora tengo
que hacer esta operación y aquí me dicen
que si es necesario
debo redondear las respuestas a la
centésima más cercana bueno voy a usar
la calculadora que tengo aquí veamos el
primero 5
5 / 19
esto es igual a punto 26 3 como a
redondear a la centésima aquí estas son
décimas centésimas va a quedar como 0.26
0.26 ahora
hago la división aquí 14 entre 19 14
entre 19 es igual a punto 2 736 que lo
redondeo a la centésima más cercana
va a ser punto 74 esto es 0.74 este de
aquí 16 entre 23 16 entre 20 y 30 puntos
695 pero que tenemos que redondear a la
centésima más cercana va a quedar como
este 9 se convierte en 10 y si éste se
convierte en 10 este 6 se convierte en 7
va a ser 0.70 y finalmente este 7 entre
23 7 entre 23 es igual a 0.30 como esto
es menor que 5 se mantiene esta
centésima no cambia
esta cantidad de más esta cantidad me
debe de dar un punto 26.74 si me va a
dar 1.70 punto 30 también me va a dar 1
vamos a verificar las respuestas
comprobar tu respuesta correcto lo
importante aquí es darnos cuenta de qué
es lo que está sucediendo una forma de
ver esto es decir que el 26 por ciento
de las personas que tienen un título
universitario tienen un ingreso inferior
a 30.000 o podemos decir que es el punto
26 de ellos y podemos decir que el 74
por ciento de éstos tienen un ingreso
superior tienen un ingreso igual o
superior a 30.000 o también podemos
decir que el punto 74 de estos
compañeros que tienen título
universitario tiene un ingreso igual o
superior a 30.000 de la misma manera
podemos decir que el 70 por ciento de
los compañeros que no tienen título
universitario tienen un ingreso inferior
a 30.000 dólares o que el punto 70 de
ellos tiene este ingreso inferior a 30
mil y que el 30 por ciento de estos
compañeros sin título tienen un ingreso
igual o superior al 30 mil y esto nos
permite contemplar
estos datos las frecuencias relativas el
total el porcentaje como nosotros
queramos pensar en ello esto de aquí
arriba son los números reales no los
porcentajes las frecuencias relativas